♫ Conjunction junction
what's your function
♫ Hooking up two boxcars
and making them function
♫ Conjunction junction
what's your function
- [Bob] That's one of my
most popular songs, huh?
Conjunction Junction.
- [Narrator] In 1971, Bob
Dorough, oh that's Bob.
- Hi.
- [Narrator] Someone asked him.
- Let's put the multiplication
tables to rock music,
and we'll call it Multiplication Rock.
What do ya think?
♫ It's Schoolhouse Rocky
- [Narrator] And so this happened:
Schoolhouse Rock.
And it ran for 64 episodes.
♫ I'm just a bill, yes I'm only a
♫ Three you can see it's a magic number
- [Narrator] The songs were iconic.
And many of them were
written and performed by Bob.
(piano music)
- I really can't say
exactly how many I wrote
for Schoolhouse Rock, but
I'd say about 22 and half.
- [Narrator] But Bob's
career isn't limited to
Schoolhouse Rock.
- Nope.
I'm a producer, even an actor.
- Caruso of the south,
men, he tried to hang.
- [Man] Shut up Kurt.
- Singer, pianist,
(piano music)
and all-around good guy.
- [Narrator] He played with Miles Davis.
- Deep down he was a sweetheart.
- [Narrator] Bob's been
writing and recording music
for over 50 years.
But he agrees that despite all of this.
- I'm probably best known for
the job I did for Schoolhouse Rock.
It was total fun.
When you have a commission,
that makes it easier,
than just to say write me a love song.
Okay, well where do I start?
But, you know, put the
multiplication tables to music,
and make it interesting.
♫ Three, six, nine, 12, 15, 18
It was easy.
♫ 21, 24, 27, 30
♫ Three, six, nine
♫ 12, 15, 18
♫ 21, 24